how's it going bros my name is beard
today we're gonna play dark mansion
it's [ __ ] laggy I don't know what's
going on with my computer lately
I'm gonna quit some [ __ ] things while
there's loge yeah
that's loading screen ever it's white
for me but it probably did suck for you
guys I'm sorry I'm sorry I should have a
loading screen but yeah I don't really
know what to expect in this one I never
know what to expect though that's the
point jeez jeez jeez that's a point come
on
I don't even remember what it was called
and that's pretty damn nice
so we wake up in this room apparently
and we answer already
I always put oil into the concert I'm
like every time I get a bottle of oil
I'm like where should I put it
and then I've all we gotta let oh my god
so much Latin I know I'm mad at my mom
okay dear Thomas today three of my
friends for hey but one of them Charles
was very strange he gave me a strange
ring before I go to bed now please try
it to come to me I think I need your
help alright let's try and help Thomas
wait I'm Thomas
okay huh are you [ __ ] kidding me told
me hey [ __ ] job no way
no [ __ ] way ah okay of course it was
a [ __ ] poof bear oh man I don't trust
anymore cuz after I played I don't know
if I know I'll put it yet but hopefully
that [ __ ] demo and I thought for sure
it was a [ __ ] poof or and woofer I
don't trust this game anymore but okay
we have a crowbar
sometimes the custom parts maker are
[ __ ] jerks but anyway oh let's try
the alcohol trick oh man
that day it works for the second time
I'm seriously I'm with just my pants
okay oh yeah we just a crowbar I'm glad
we're alright can't use a crowbar really
ah okay we need to find a key that
let it be let it be let it be let it be
well I got so many freaking tender boxes
don't let them oh yeh lighten and I'm
mad about a bum
but seriously though where's the key
nothing tell me where's the key mr.
chair I don't really know I mean I think
I you know but I'm not gonna tell you
I'm gonna make you look man
give me the shares now forgive me it
says for what yeah for bringing a
[ __ ] poof rap that the five seconds
maybe there's a door over here that I
didn't see that I can use a crowbar
no no there's nothing here there's the
key
that's underneath the bed okay lads go
I got a key to cup game we all cookie
and I'm taking you with me mr. chair
it's Europe damn fine sham I love her
fool oil but no [ __ ] Lander let's go
mr. sheriff oh man this doesn't look
it's good I don't think so either
better remember beating share mode okay
freakin Shamu okay look share mode
activated
peep yeah good that wash yeah good idea
that like no one thinks I'm something
else in a chair okay I don't trust okay
I was like book overlooking bookshelves
for sivanna you never know right okay
prated I am nice paintings here
ah I found the key yeah I love with you
what have you been well
what are you doing in there you need to
get out no okay okay step on it whatever
you say man you met to my hallucination
right but do you think the next will be
hallucination - but I only met one
hallucination did you met my
hallucination that's not everyday
everyday I'm hustling every day and it
stops the phone and says you know ah man
it's locked - can you see key huh
crowbar no I can't use a [ __ ] it's the
founder where are you oh there we go
this way today seriously focus
I couldn't could I use the key here yeah
okay good good
ah don't be stuck Stalin series of them
I just allow monies gold in addition
it's so much better but I don't I'm not
sure if I'm done in here
I mean there's okay that was second in
Russia oh oh that was the same Oh her
getting [ __ ] [ __ ] hi I know how you
doing hello my name is Shane
okay this don't get distracted right now
oh my laughs to scare the living crap
out of me yeah we got the liner I just
feel a lot better when I have the liner
and I'm not gonna lie
oh man that Italy's nation wasn't pretty
hello's an energetic one I know that
makes sense
okay I think we can go on out then I
pick something up night and fiction ah
come on don't drop me beauty I will kill
you I died totally I will kill you and
stop making noises okay okay let's go
here
oh man at least a firearm Oh ma'am
Oh
I [ __ ] who I hate poo first I hate
[ __ ] hate [ __ ] [ __ ] up stripping
balls damn oh [ __ ] oh good I thought it
was walking towards me oh it's a penis
monster literally I told you again guys
about his penis it's so huge
it's ridiculous okay where the [ __ ] did
he go though
seriously though where is he
where the [ __ ] are you brah can I use
the crowbar no of course not
that means I have to find something
there we go what is that it's so tiny
that's what she said but whatever I
picked up great let's go I'm huh it's a
hollow needle right yeah okay penis
monster where are you mr. penis ah what
are you doing trying to hide from me
mr. barrel baths
I hate barrel so much I can't use that
really I came from that right okay
I expect bad things beyond this room why
can I never use that
a bounce get the [ __ ] out of here
barrels oh yeah you pull backwards to
open these it's so annoying
I don't know huh oh no no oh [ __ ] I hate
water monster okay this oh man let's
read this close the door and watch your
step so maybe you better off of course
thank you ha ha ha I just wanted to get
[ __ ] out of here oh man
Oh
I don't trust this room I don't trust
water I don't [ __ ] trust water man
okay we got that nine out of um and I
know you're very good at running keep on
going
I'm not even running what are you
talking about okay come on not even
running I don't know how to sign I think
the water months are supposed to be here
but maybe it bugged out there something
oh man it's a bro bro they cut me in
half seriously but I ate the key so you
can take it take the key I do it for you
buddy
Oh bro bro don't die on me bro bro bro
how are you I just want the freakin key
right now her old lady
rah rah rah blah blah blah
why did you do that pretty I nearly
drowned okay
I'll put you there bro it's pretty good
if she go in an extra dollar
close the door better again and then
you'll see what you live to death
Oh kind of I'll do that
let's go ornate and out but we have to
close the door
gotta listen to him right huh right son
okay let's go in here
housing the dark
oh man oh oh oh oh wait you can come
after me right oh they're like Dingling
inches again dangling living whooping
ooh
best day ever okay
quick
hey Petey I've been waiting for you
Petey
I'm a share you know you can't just
ignore us anymore
okay I'm sorry mr. chair
showers are feeling too you know we have
feelings too you know you can't just
ignore us it's not cool
man
okay I'm sorry mr. Sherr I'm taking with
me now okay it's okay Peter I'm okay I
forgive you
don't worry chère Mon activate it okay
and we got more or Latin that oh sorry
excited Portia and some tinderbox and
I'm wasting my lantern but whatever and
we got to keep
I have to look everything got a look
everyone does he never know if you don't
know now you know let's go mr. chair yes
new adventures and let's go here
Oh pretty cool room actually typewriter
hi Hey
Knight Riders oh it's getting action
Emma I hate them
we got saved in another note hello
stranger I hide the key in the she'll
find it and I hope you can end this
crazy [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] can I climb this
so he had the key in the bookshelves and
there's like a million books so that's
great
let's use mr. chair now I mean you
always use me you never huh
and hid them in the [ __ ] shouts why
typewriter
what are you do it yeah type writer okay
in the bookshelf why am I looking there
them okay somewhere in the bookshop
Thank You mr. chair I'll give you
my greatest thank you okay
that's China's
it's got it don't fall down on me mr.
Sherr mr. sheriff you're really a share
okay now this looks pretty well gluts
thing's gotta be this looks pretty well
glued to so it's gotta be I want this
shelf
come on share cooperate
I thought
all right side pick it up yeah hi Katie
hi imagine trunking I got you okay I
wonder why I still have the crowbar
what oh man naked guys in the closet
naked guy in a cop I picked up an oath
and I didn't read it said nothing
well great and now Oh break - growling
look oh he's stuck he's stuck he was
dying
oh man yeah so that was dark mansion one
I hope you enjoyed it [ __ ] annoying
music ah you stop it Jesus penis
I actually remember that name I think he
made some other stuff but Jesus penis
come on alright I hope you enjoyed it it
was kind of buggy I think there were
some scarce we missed out on because it
was too glitchy Ben thumbs up that many
I think it favors in my life and I'll
see you tomorrow ok bye
okay ah [ __ ] he comes through anyway the
barrels did nothing okay take em lock in
mr. chair it's working it's working baby